soon europe / sensations
bonsoir et bienvenue dans une europe /
sensation une émission enregistrée au
parlement européen de strasbourg est
réalisée en association avec tv 78 voici
le sommaire de ce nouveau numéro
l'eurodéputé caroline rousse sera notre
invité nous évoquerons avec elle la
situation en haïti l'un des pays les
plus pauvres du monde
la gpa la gestation pour autrui est
interdite en france mais ailleurs dans
trois pays d'europe elle est autorisée
et encadrée nous verrons comment ça se
passe chez nos voisins mais tout de
suite ce jour là le 16 février 2001 la
signature du traité de nice plus de
détails avec alberto believe aka chargé
de mission europe direct cinéma
so d'europe ce jour là
le 26 février 2001 les ministres des
affaires étrangères des différents états
membres signent un traité qui est
sûrement très mal connu par les citoyens
européens au vu de sa complexité en
effet il a été élaboré pour réformer les
institutions avant le grand
élargissement de 2004 et donc pour un
assurer le bon fonctionnement face à
cette transformation majeure de l'union
européenne
trois grands axes principaux ont été
développées lors de la mise au point de
ce traité préalable à l'intégration
européenne des pays issus de l'ancien
bloc soviétique
ces trois axes comprennent la
composition et le fonctionnement de
l'institution open la procédure
décisionnelle au sein du conseil de
l'union européenne et les coopérations
renforcées le traité a été ratifié
ensuite par les états membres par voie
parlementaire ou par référendum
le traité de nice est entrée en vigueur
le 1er février 2003 concernant la
réforme des institutions le traité de
nice à renforcer le rôle du parlement la
procédure de codécision a plus
aujourd'hui procédure législative
ordinaire partagé par le conseil c'est
en a des nouvelles dispositions comme la
lutte contre les discriminations la
cohésion économique et sociale les
questions concernant les visas l'asile
et l'immigration
il régit aussi le financement des partis
politiques européens et le nombre
maximal de sièges qui passe à 732 par ce
traité on définit aussi la question
délicate des modalités de vote au sein
du conseil
l'unanimité et la majorité qualifiée la
prise de décisions par majorité
qualifiée a été étendu à 27 domaine
supplémentaires notamment agriculture
environnement énergie et transport ce
système de pondération en fonction de la
population existait déjà mais le traité
réévaluent le poids de chaque pays
auquel un nombre différent de voix sont
attribués en fonction de sa taille avant
la réforme du traité de lisbonne se
traitait disposé que pour qu'une
décision sur la prouver 255 voix sur 345
pour 27 pays membres doivent être
recueillis dans certains cas un état
membre peut faire valoir la clause
démographique et donc demandé de
vérifier que la majorité aux petits
correspondent à au moins 60 2% de la
population européenne
après cette demande si la proportion
n'est pas atteinte l'acte n'est pas
adopté une autre réforme majeure
concerne l'assouplissement des règles
sur la coopération renforcé sa mise en
oeuvre est donc facilitée huit pays
minimum en le droit de coopérer de
manière plus étroite que les autres pour
défendre une position commune sur des
domaines importantes comme la politique
étrangère commune à cette étape je vous
concède que les rouages de lieux peuvent
être un peu complexe mais il faut aussi
mettre en place les modalités opportune
pour faire vivre la démocratie
l'une des valeurs fondamentales en
europe
zone europe l'invité politique
je reçois caroline rousse bonjour
bonjour alors vous êtes eurodéputés
membres du groupe les verts alliance
libre européenne alors ensemble nous
allons évoquer la crise politique qui a
lieu actuellement en haïti l'un des pays
les plus pauvres du monde alors si on
prend l'histoire récente haïti c'est a
été durement touchée par un sanglant
coup d'état dans les années 90 en 2010
c'est un séisme qui a fait plus de 220
mille morts 300 mille blessés et en
juillet 2021 le prise au président de la
république d'haïti a été assassiné alors
certains pays qui est meurtri
actuellement marquée par une forte
instabilité qu'elle soit politique ou
sanitaire peut-être avant d'aller plus
loin est-ce qu'on pourrait planter le
décor comme on dit qu'est ce qui
explique une telle situation dans ce
pays alors comme vous l'avez dit c'est
un des pays les plus pauvres au monde
on a eu un certain nombre de d'épisodes
en effet au niveau de ce pays
c'est un pays déjà qui a des problèmes
au niveau climat puisqu'il ya des
phénomènes climatiques importants il ya
un réchauffement climatique aussi et
puis il ya la situation politique qui
est vraiment problématique dans le pays
puisque on parle beaucoup d'humanitaires
mais on a un problème politique au
niveau du pays avec énormément de
corruption il ya énormément de choses
qui se sont passées l'assassinât du
président moïse
on a signé une résolution d'urgence
avant cet assassinat puisqu'on me
l'année dernière on a signé une
résolution d'urgence sur haïti en
dénonçant tous les problèmes qu'ils
avaient sur haïti suite à tout ça il ya
eu ce qui s'est passé
de l'assassinât du président moïse et
ensuite il ya eu ensuite un tremblement
de terre donc se sont énormément de
circonstances qui ont fait que le pays
aujourd'hui étant dans le chaos comme en
explique ce chaos ce pays haïti et sur
la même île que la république
dominicaine la république dominicaine
est un pays plutôt prospère il ya du
tourisme et on passe la frontière et là
c'est le cas où vous dit comment il en
explique ça en effet les deux pays sont
des des similarités puisque ils ont
connu tous les deux la colonisation ils
ont connu tous les deux une dictature
mais ils ont pris des chemins différents
qui ont fait que haïti est
un pays qui est totalement corrompu
donc la république dominicaine a sorti
je tairai son épingle du jeu par rapport
à haïti on a cette corruption qui est
omniprésente en haïti qui a fait que le
pays
n'a pas pris
le même axe que la république
dominicaine justement vous avez eu
l'occasion d'en parler il ya dans un
webinaire il n'y a pas très longtemps
vous avez parlé de l'accès aux services
de base aux soins la scolarité qui est
parfois impossible pour une partie de la
population il ya une situation qui vous
préoccupe particulièrement c'est la
situation des femmes pensent wheels en
effet la situation des femmes elle est
très préoccupante d'ailleurs j'avais
signé une tribune avec d'autres
collègues femmes au parlement européen
quand on voit les gants qui se sont
installés quand on voit les violences
faites aux femmes les viols qui sont
faits en toute impunité des viols
collectifs sur les femmes
quand on voit ce qui se passe au niveau
des filles qui ne peuvent plus aller à
l'école aujourd'hui et qui sont
confrontés à ces viols et le no6 c'est
la situation est vraiment très très
préoccupante au niveau des femmes et des
filles dans le pays il ya cette
situation qui est qui est préoccupante
mais est encore récemment un médecin
sans frontières une ong qui a suspendu
ses activités dans un des quartiers
pauvres de la capitale port au prince
sans le travail des humanitaires le pays
est ce qu'ils risquent pas de s'enfoncer
encore plus est ce qu'on n'est pas en
train de délaisser ce pays mais oui
forcément le problème c'est qu'il n'y
avait que médecin 30 sans frontières qui
était encore sur le pays malheureusement
la situation en haïti et les
catastrophiques au niveau des gangs
armés et les ong ne travaille pas en
toute sérénité et cette hausse de 58%
des kidnappings en haïti comme oui c'est
ça on y avait à un moment donné on a
dénoncé 5 qui n'appliquent ou par jour
ce qui est quand même une situation
aberrante et les ong ne peuvent pas
travailler dans des situations normales
dans le pays et médecins sans frontières
justement s'est retiré ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui
en termes d' aide eh ben ils sont un
petit peu délaissé les haïtiens
justement est-ce que c'est un pays qui a
aucune comparaison dans le monde
justement au niveau criminalité comment
est ce que on peut aider ce pays
justement pour lutter contre ça et
pourquoi est ce que le gouvernement ne
fait rien sur ça alors on peut les aider
en lançant justement de l'aide
humanitaire le problème c'est que
l'accès aux ong aujourd'hui elle est un
petit peu
compliqué puisque justement ces ong se
sont retirés du pays quand on dit que le
gouvernement ne fait rien alors le
gouvernement nous dit oui nous on fait
mais qu'est ce qu'ils font aujourd'hui
on se pose quand même un certain nombre
de questions
puisque on a
une violence qui devient violence
institutionnelle puisque aujourd'hui
malheureusement on n'arrive pas à les
aider on est sur un blocus total et ça
c'est absolument pas possible on le
disait le président de la république
d'haïti dont il a été assassiné en
juillet 2021 le premier ministre haïtien
ariel henry ce maintien au pouvoir
depuis l'été dernier dernier il a un
projet de nouvelle constitution
d'élection de réformes on est en pleine
crise institutionnelle dans le pays en
plus des gangs en plus de ce qui se
passe plusieurs élections qui étaient
prévues ont été reportées c'est un peu
confus est ce que la population a payé
les frais et est ce que on n'est pas
dans un nouveau régime qui se met en
place c est ce qu il faut pas en avoir
peur alors on est sur une population qui
a qui est très craintive aujourd'hui
puisque justement la date du 7 février
était une date plus ou moins butoir
j'avais fait un webinaire justement
juste avant le 7 février pour qu'on
puisse en discuter et en fait on est au
mois d'avril mais s'est absolument rien
passé est ce qu'aujourd'hui on peut
avoir des élections
sachant qu'il ya une forte criminalité
sachant qu'il ya des gangs sachant qu'il
ya de la corruption est-ce qu'on peut
aujourd'hui avoir une élection et
organiser des élections qui soient
démocratiques j'en doute mais en plus
vous parle on parle de d'élection on
parle de corruption aussi dans ce pays
il me semble on parle de détournement
des fonds du programme petrocaribe donc
c'est une alliance de qu'une coopération
énergétique entre le venezuela et les
autres pays des caraïbes un audit est
réclamée en ce qui concerne les fonds
européens bien sûr est ce qu'il ya un
soupçon des détournements de fonds et
qu'en est il aujourd'hui alors on avait
demandé un audit justement en commission
justement par rapport à ce détournement
de fonds sur petrocaribe il ya eu une
élévation des consciences les gens se
sont retrouvés dans la rue les gens se
sont mobilisés mais l'audit de la cour
des comptes européenne qui était dans la
résolution d'urgence qu'on a signé au
mois de mai dernier on n'a pas eu de
nouvelles à ce sujet donc c'est quelque
chose qu'on va relancer parce que
aujourd'hui il n'y a aucun contrôle il
ya on a aucune transparence en ce qui
concerne l'allocation des fonds
européens on peut rappeler qu'il ya un
an mais 2021 une résolution sur la
situation en haïti a été signé au
parlement européen c'est alors ce que
vous pouvez nous rappeler les points
principaux déjà deux fils alors cette
résolution donc elle a été signée en mai
2021 on a eu un débat en plénière on
avait demandé à l'union européenne
justement de prendre ses distances avec
jo bonnet le moïse puisque on était en
mai il a été assassiné au mois de
juillet on avait demandé aussi à la
communauté internationale d'aider le
peuple haïtien
pour renforcer un système judiciaire qui
soit indépendant et vigoureux pour qu'on
arrête un petit peu d'avoir ces viols
en toute impunité etc et puis on a
demandé un soutien aussi à une
transition démocratique qui soit ouverte
inclusive pour faire en sorte d'avoir
des élections démocratiques
on en est encore loin aujourd'hui suite
à cette résolution malheureusement il
s'est pas passé grand chose moi j'ai
relancé avec un webinaire
malheureusement en plus d'accorder son
soutien et de dire qu'on est présent au
lieu de simplement dire qu'on est
présente qu'est ce que peut faire
l'europe physiquement sur le terrain est
ce que finalement accorder de l'argent
ou accordées les aides c'est quelque
chose qui est facile à dire qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire sur le terrain sur le
terrain
on peut justement
reprendre de l'aide humanitaire le
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui on a
toujours ce problème d'accès et ce chaos
au niveau des gangs donc à part mettre
une pression justement sur la commission
européenne pour avancer dans le sens à
aider les haïtiens
et revenir sur le sujet reprendre cette
résolution d'urgence qu'on a signé en
mai pour remettre cette pression
aujourd'hui il ya un manque de
considération niveau international de la
situation en haïti tout à fait oui il ya
un manque total de considération et
lors de ce webinaire le dialogue a été
un petit peu rompus entre
la société civile et les instances
européennes donc on a vraiment un gros
problème au niveau
d'ouverture c'est pour ça qu'il faut
continuer à mettre une pression sur les
institutions européennes pour haïti
justement et faire en sorte que cette
résolution elles soient mises en
application merci beaucoup caroline
rousse d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle
que vous êtes eurodéputés membres du
groupe les verts alliance libre
européenne merci à vous
sous une robe chez nos voisins et chez
nos voisins ça se passe comment c'est
notre rubrique en partenariat avec a
choisi l'institut des hautes études de
journalisme de montpellier cette semaine
la gpa avec chaque petit gars là juste à
sion pour autrui cette pratique médicale
qui permet d'avoir des enfants par mère
porteuse est un sujet encore tabou en
france alors que bien d'autres pays
comme le royaume uni l'argentine
l'australie ou encore les etats-unis ont
autorisé la pratique de la gpa la france
interdit ce dispositif principalement
pour des raisons d'éthique alors la gpa
consiste à transplanter un embryon dans
dont les parents biologiques sont dans
l'incapacité de fournir les gammes est
nécessaire à la procréation suite à un
don d'ovocytes et ou de sperme les
embryons sont transplantées dans
l'utérus d'une autre femme
habituellement appelée mère gestatrice
ou tout simplement mère porteuse cette
pratique médicale concerne
principalement les personnes infertile
ou les couples homosexuels qui ne
peuvent pas ou ne souhaitent pas avoir
recours à l'adoption
mais alors pourquoi cette pratique pose
des problèmes posent des problèmes
d'éthique en france la gpa est interdite
au nom du principe de non
marchandisation du corps humain un
principe selon lequel le corps humain ne
serait pas considérée comme une chose
pouvant faire l'objet d'un contrat ou
d'une convention car ce qui est
considéré comme l'un des gros soucis de
la gba c'est le statut de la mère
porteuse ces femmes se font souvent
rémunérés en échange de leur grossesse
on parle alors de gpa commercial comme
on en trouve souvent aux états unis ou
alors de gpa altruiste ou souvent c'est
une membre ou une proche de la famille
qui va porter l'embryon gratuitement
comme c'est le cas dans plusieurs pays
européens comme la belgique ou encore le
danemark le fait pour une femme de
porter l'embryon d'une autre contre
rémunération ou non est interdite dans
notre pays depuis
1994 après avoir été tolérés pendant un
temps l'assemblée nationale en est à sa
troisième lecture du projet de loi
bioéthique qui déterminera si la gpa
sera légalisé en france sous contrôle
strict et concernant les français 66 %
des couples homosexuels sont favorables
à la gpa ainsi que 53 % des couples
hétérosexuels
une première en france c'est la première
fois que plus de la moitié des couples
hétérosexuels sont d'accord avec la jpa
zone europe voyage
on en vient maintenant à notre rubrique
voyager dans l'assiette cette semaine le
chef pâtissier nicolas paciello de cinq
sens paris nous dévoile sa recette de la
tarte tatin salut tout le monde moi je
rappelle nicolas paciello je suis chef
pâtissier de cinq sens paris une maison
que j'ai cofondé avec william assouline
depuis maintenant un an et trois mois et
aujourd'hui on va réaliser une tarte
tatin 7h tu atteins elle est un peu l à
peu spécial parce que c'est une recette
que j'ai fait pour le concours des
meilleurs ouvriers de france en 2018
alors pour réaliser la pâte sucrée on
aura besoin de farine de sucre glace de
poudre d'amandes de beurre du sel et 1,9
à température ambiante c'est beaucoup
mieux parce qu'après s'il sort du frigo
et l'effroi ça à faire durcir la pâte
pour réaliser la crème pâtissière on
aura besoin de la crème un peu de beurre
du sucre de la vanille des bonnes gousse
de vanille fraîche
une feuille de gélatine des jaunes et 2
pour le coup de la fécule de pomme de
terre et pour finir on va réaliser un
caramel donc on aura besoin de sucre dos
on va rebaptiser ça avec un peu de fèves
de tonka
une pointe de fleur de sel et puis les
pommes forcément sans pomme va fermer
tarte tatin
et ben on va commencer du coup pour
réaliser la pâte sucrée on va mettre
dans un bol la farine on va prendre le
beurre alors pas forcément pommade moi
j'ai sorti du frigo donc les dés sont
assez sont assez dur et ça permet de
bien sable et la pâte donc là on va
vraiment voir le mélange du beurre froid
qui ce qui se dit ce sable avec avec la
avec la farine c'est important de pas
avoir un beurre trop chaud après il va
être fondue sera moussa a plus faire
un mélange crémeux là on va rester sur
quelque chose d'assez d' assez solide
alors on sait que c'est bon quand tous
les tous les morceaux de beurre soit à
peu près la même somme à peu près
homogène en termes de taille en fait
parce qu'au début il ya des gros
morceaux et tout va ce qu'on va voir ça
va vraiment donner ces espèces d'aspect
vraiment sableux voilà on voit bien que
ça devient comme de la poudre fait le
beurre c'est bien mélanger la farine
mais n'est pas fendu donc à ce moment là
on va pouvoir ajouter le sucre glace
et la poudre d'amandes
pas pour l'as mélangez le tout et puis
on va rajouter la température ambiante
et le sel
tout l'ensemble commencent à se mélanger
et l'oeuf donc le gras le beurre la
farine et ça ça fait plus qu'une pâte
et bien mélanger ya pas de morceaux
dedans
et ça je vais finir sur la table
donc là je mets un tout petit peu de
farine sur la table hop je fais sortir
on peut voir qu'elle se travaille déjà
très bien on perd voilà je finis à la
main donc là on voit vraiment une belle
pâte bien homogène
voire une fois qu'on a récupéré une fois
qu'on a une pâte homogène on va la
mettre au frigo pendant 30 minutes
voilà donc la balle en jeu détail c'est
pas de sucre et qu'on a un peu étalé à
entre 3 et 5 mm on va là détaillé qu'un
cercle qui est un tout petit peu plus
grand que notre moule on voit ça de tout
dépend de la taille de votre moule il ya
toujours allez un bon centimètre ou deux
centimètres au dessus voilà ensuite on
va foncer le fond de tarte donc c'est à
dire qu'on va appliquer la pâte à
l'intérieur
l'idée c'est de vraiment ramener la pâte
dans l'angle du fond de tarte en
essayant de garder la même épaisseur
partout voilà une belle régularité et
après une fois qu'on est bien au fond on
étale bien contre les parois voilà je
passe plusieurs fois pour vraiment avoir
une régularité donc très bonne
régularité partout on vient mettre un
coup de lame sur les bords pour vraiment
avoir une finition très net et c'est à
ce moment là qu'on peut vraiment
s'apercevoir que la l'épaisseur elle est
vraiment très nette on va juste la
piquer un tout petit peu au milieu faire
un trou au lieu d'en faire plusieurs non
récurrents histoire que l'air et puisse
sortir et que ça fasse pas des des
cloques sur la sur la pâte et on va
l'enfourner à 170° pendant à peu près 25
30 minutes
au bout d'à peu près une demi heure on
voit on a un fond de tarte qui est bien
doré bien cuisse on va le sortir va
laisser refroidir et on va le démouler
alors ensuite on va passer sur la crème
pâtissière pour faire une bonne crème
pâtissière il faut de la crème des
gousses de vanille fraîche une feuille
de gélatine que j'ai fait tremper dans
l'eau froide de la fécule de pomme de
terre ou de la maïzena du beurre des
jaunes et du sucre donc on va commencer
par faire chauffer doucement la crème je
vais couper mais vanille en deux on va
vraiment se mettre au milieu on va bien
la couper en deux pour la séparer et
ensuite on va venir gratter
l'intérieur
voilà
on va les mettre dans la crème et je
vais aussi rajouter
la gauche
voilà on va porter la crème à ébullition
et on va laisser infuser pendant 20
minutes
hors du feu dans un récipient on va
mettre la fécule
le sucre
revenir mélanger et on va ajouter de
dans
le jaune
je vais verser un tout petit peu de
crème sur mon premier mélange
histoire de le déléguer un petit peu
maintenant on va passer entièrement dans
la casserole
canton vert se mélangent comme ça
contient d eux ça va cuire assez
rapidement voilà maintenant on remet sur
le sueur sur la plaque à induction
et comme il ya la fécule de dans les eux
savent accueillir et ça va épaissir
et on va voir le changement assez assez
radicale de la crémière très rapidement
la vue elle se transforme en cette crème
assez épaisse
il faut surtout pas laisser en place
sinon ça va brûler dans le fond de la
casserole voilà l'idée c'est de une fois
qu'on est à ce point là c'est de la
faire cuire une minute pas plus pour
vraiment qu'elle soit parfaitement cuite
on va on va essorez la feuille de
gélatine qui a trompé pendant à peu près
20 minutes dans l'eau bien froide on va
la mettre directement dans la crème et
je vais en même temps rajouter mon
beurre et on va arrêter la cuisson la
crème comme ça on va mélanger
voilà voilà débarrassé dans un bol et la
faire refroidir assez rapidement au
frigo
on peut voir qu'on a déjà une crème
pâtissière une bonne crème pâtissière
bien vanier voilà maintenant on va
attaquer le caramel cuisson et la
cuisson de la pomme donc là on a besoin
simplement de sucre dos une pincée de
fleur de sel
la fève de tonka et des pommes pour
commencer on va réaliser
un caramel à sec pour commencer un
caramel à sec à la maison va prendre sa
casserole et on va verser un fonds de
sucre dans la casserole vraiment pour
pouvoir toujours avoir le contrôle du
moment où il va commencer à caraméliser
si on verserait toute la quantité de
sucre dans la casserole me reverrez pas
le fond est souvent c'est comme ça qu'on
brûle un caramel on a là le carnet qui
est bien cuit on voit il commence à
mousser un peu on le pousse à c'est fort
quand même une belle couleur bien
caramel on a de l'eau bouillante et on
va des glaces et le caramel avec cet os
[Musique]
dans la casserole il fait noir et voilà
on est un petit caramel qui est quand
même assez liquide donc maintenant qu'on
va éplucher nos pommes on va les
découper la pomme en dea en petits dés
d'à peu près un vilain 1 cm 1 cm et demi
alors ensuite on va mettre nos pommes
dans un mois j'ai un bac en inox mais on
peut très bien mettre un pyrex en verre
sur laquelle on peut mettre un couvercle
vient mettre les pommes à l'intérieur de
sue jeu parsemer de fleur de sel
car une fois qu'on a nos pommes dans
dans le bac on va verser le caramel
qu'on a réalisé juste avant quasiment à
hauteur hauteur des pommes pour finir
pour l'assaisonner on va rapper cette
fameuse fève de tonka
on va couvrir ça
et ça on va mettre au four à peu près à
140° pendant une heure mais temps en
temps il faudra regarder la cuisson des
pommes elles vont cuire elles vont
confirmer en fait elles vont absorber
tout le caramel qui à l'intérieur et
l'on comprend deux couleurs vraiment
très foncé alors là on a tous qui est
prêt notre crème qui a refroidi on a les
pommes qu'on peut voir elles sont bien
confié bien translucide on les a laissé
refroidir
on a récupéré un jus ce que j'appelle le
jus de cuisson des pommes donc ce
caramel qui si vraiment qu'on a récupéré
après après avoir cuit on a les fonds de
tarte alors je vais être au fond de la
tarte un peu de crème pâtissière je vais
venir prendre mes pommes
à venir garnir
garnir le fond de tarte
voilà j'essaie de ne pas abîmer mes cube
pour sa phase très joli et pas compotée
on va garder ces morceaux
très gourmand ensuite pour finir
on prend du nappage neutre et on va le
mélanger avec ce jus de cuisson
donc ce caramel qui a pris le goût de
pomme et de fêtes de tonka et près
délicatement avec un pinceau on va venir
napper les pommes pour apporter un peu
de brillance et pour finir à l'aide
d'une petite poche si on en a quand on
prend cette crème qu'on a mis en dessous
ça va porter ces petits bijoux cette
couche de gourmandise et on va venir
mettre des petits points voilà donc au
bout d'une petite pâte sucrée une crème
et ses pommes bien qu'armés lisez bien
cuites dans l'eure dans leur caramel un
hôte ya une petite tarte avec un fond
bien croustillant donc ce que je vous
disais un peu au début la particularité
de cette date 1 c'est d'avoir les pommes
cuites aussi dans un caramel mais d'être
dans une sur une pâte sucrée bien
croustillantes et avec cette gourmandise
ans ou de crème pâtissière donc tout ce
qu'il faut pour passer un super dessert
zone europe c'est terminé pour
aujourd'hui merci aux équipes techniques
du parlement européen de strasbourg vous
pouvez retrouver cette émission en
podcast audio et vidéo sur notre site et
notre application radio sensations et
aussi sur tv 78 je vous donne rendez
vous la semaine prochaine bonne soirée
sonos robe sur sensations
sont europe
[Musique]